talk to me about what's happening now
your wife and some of your colleagues
have headed to kabul airport what
happened next
my wife and my country manager who is 34
weeks pregnant
they were told by the evacuation teams
that they need to get to kabul airport
within the next hour
to get their flights their evacuation
flights out
there is i just listened to that press
three things that you have in the
background
there is no security on the outside of
kabul airport they got caught and
crushed in a stampede this is a 34 34
week pregnant woman and my wife came
sporting a stampede they were at the
gates
of kabul airport on the side had been
told to go i was in cons with the quick
reaction force on the other side of the
gate
british and american and as a royal
marine commando i am absolutely furious
with these soldiers because they refuse
to go out of that camp to rescue those
people
who get them inside the safety of kabul
airfield
boris johnson and all of the senior
staff of this government need to know
what a complete cluster they are making
of this withdrawal from afghanistan
people are gonna die
outside it is not secure
and if the british military are there
and they will not get outside and rescue
some of the people that they've been
sent
to get out of kabul safely then what is
the point in them being here
by creating this withdrawal there the
government the americans especially joe
biden have created undue panic and
stress
and nothing is going to be achieved
there are still thousands of afghans
trying to fight to get into an airfield
to get on an airplane to escape the mess
we made at the moment i don't know where
my wife is they had to finally they
managed to pull out my
um country manager to get her out for
crush along with her one in your one and
a half year old son
and they are now trying to make their
way back to
another secure location um near the
kabul airfield and i'm being told
authority so they have to come into this
secure location by the british military
again somebody needs to get aggressive
if they are injured or hurt i will
personally hold boris johnson and the
whole of this government to account
depend not acceptable
pen you're understandably upset and i
completely understand but from what
you're telling me it's the situation
outside of the airport and getting to
the airport that is a problem we saw
obviously um helicopters airlifting us
embassy staff because they said that the
roads weren't safe to travel airlifted
them to the airport
sorry just in terms of getting to the
airport is that the problem do we know
what happens inside the airport because
i'm looking at pictures that were taken
from kabul airport today of chaotic
scenes on the tarmac
yeah they they do not have
this that airport is not secure
i am getting fed up of the politicians
and i've just listened to that press
read from from america trying to
convince the world they've got a handful
on this they do not
this is a masterclass an absolute master
class in how to do everything wrong in a
withdrawal from a country that we have
completely messed up
we cannot get to kabul airport
outside of that perimeter the taliban
now control everything there are
thousands thousands of desperate afghans
who are trying to get into an airport
and then in between you've got the state
department or you've got the foreign
officer saying please make your way to
the airport and when you get here then
you can get a flight out well we can't
get to the airport forest johnson and
when we do the soldiers you sent
refused to open the gate to let expats
who have been told to be there and one
of them a 34-week pregnant woman with a
one and a half year old
child
they left them in a crush
i am beyond furious
this government along with joe biden
have created an absolutely unimaginable
horror show of withdrawal from
afghanistan
and somebody is going to die because
there is no control
outside of that air force
something needs to be done
they call a cobra meeting they call
whatever but they need to now
get people
to actually control this situation
if
i'm desperate now because i need to know
where my wife is where my country
manager is where her son is
this is unacceptable i mean this is i've
i know i've i've been on uh
a lot in the last few weeks but i
actually thought the government was
getting a handle on this they're not
people are not telling the truth about
what is going on in cup we're trying to
make it sound like yes we send a lot of
troops in it's secure the airport is not
they're not going to be start i think
you just said 9 000 people a day how are
they going to get 9 000 people into that
yeah
airport
johnson if you listen to this you need
to now call a meeting and you need to
find out exactly what is going on in the
ground here because people are going to
get injured they're going to get hurt